depuis le début de la crise nous voyons
régulièrement ces images choquantes de
centaines de jeunes faisant la queue
pour recevoir des paniers alimentaires
emmanuel macron avait annoncé le projet
de revenus d'engagement pour les jeunes
le 12 juillet dernier ce dispositif
devait permettre d'atteindre l'ensemble
des jeunes sans travail ou sans
formation mais son ambition a depuis été
revues à la baisse en réduisant de plus
de moitié le nombre de jeunes pouvant y
aspirer soit moins de cinq cent mille
jeunes et aujourd'hui il semblerait même
que le projet soit enterré un article du
journal libération datant d'aujourd'hui
cite à ce sujet un élu déclarant je cite
ce n'est pas au moment où l'on manque de
serveurs ou de personnes sur les
chantiers qu'il faut laisser penser
qu'on va filer 500 euros aux jeunes
c'est donc ce à l'horizon qu'on propose
à une partie de la jeunesse la précarité
travail et tétouan
concrètement madame la ministre qu'en
est il de ce dispositif qui pourra y
aspirer si ce projet voit le jour et que
comptez-vous faire de celles et ceux qui
aujourd'hui n'ont d'autre choix que
d'aller à la soupe populaire où
s'inscrire sur une plateforme
la parole à madame la ministre du
travail de l'emploi et d'un chercheur
madame bord vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur pascal savoldelli
contrairement à ce que vous laissez
entendre aucun président de la
république n'a autant agit en faveur de
la jeunesse alors que notre pays a
traversé l'une des crises l'une de ces
crises les plus graves
3 millions de jeunes ont pu trouver un
emploi un apprentissage une formation ou
un accompagnement grâce au plan un gène
une solution ces 9 milliards d'euros que
nous avons mobilisé et les résultats
sont là le taux d'emploi des jeunes est
revenue à son niveau d'avant crise et je
rappelle qu'après la crise de 2008 2009
le taux de chômage des jeunes avait
explosé de plus de 30%
désormais la reprise économique ouvre de
nombreuses perspectives d'emploi ou
d'apprentissage dans les jeunes
bénéficient pleinement nous devrions
égaler voire dépasser le record de plus
de 1 125 mille apprentis atteint en 2020
mais notre volonté c'est que cette
reprise bénéficier également aux jeunes
les plus éloignés de l'emploi c'est tout
le sens des travaux que nous menons à la
demande du président de république et il
ne faut pas forcément croire tout ce qui
est écrit dans les journaux monsieur le
sénateur il nous faut tout d'abord
redoubler d'efforts pour aller vers ceux
qui ne viennent pas spontanément dans
les missions locales pour eux je
souhaite construire en lien étroit avec
le ministre en charge des solidarités
olivier ferrand et la ministre en charge
du logement emmanuelle wargon des
parcours sur mesure mobilisant les
missions locales mais aussi les
associations de terrain et les
collectivités ce que nous voulons c'est
également amélioré les parcours
d'accompagnement en capitalisant sur les
solutions qui ont fait leurs preuves
dans le cadre du plan un jeune une
solution les immersion en entreprise les
prépa apprentissage les formations
qualifiantes
les travaux sont en cours de
finalisation et j'espère pouvoir compter
sur votre soutien dans le cadre de
l'examen du projet de loi de finances 2
pour 2022 notre volonté c'est de
permettre à chaque jeune d'accéder au
plus vite à l'emploi je pense que c'est
un combat qui devrait pouvoir la
rassembler largement monsieur le
sénateur
madame la ministre vous avez parlé de
publication
je vais vous montrer l'armée du salut
l'armée du salut la une de son rapport
d'activité un livreur qui vient manger
ça ça vous plaît comme aux médias après
la deuxième chose que je veux vous dire
et je le dis devant mes collègues ce que
vous venez de me répondre de nous
répondre à nous tous ici c'est que la
promesse du président macron est enterré
vous n'en avez pas du tout parlé dans
votre intervention vous avez enterrer
une promesse sociale voilà ce que vous
voulez faire
la dernière chose que je vais vous dire
madame la ministre il s'agit pas de b
mais la situation est trop grave pour
nous faire un bilan
d'autosatisfaction à valeur morale c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible madame
la ministre
c'est pas acceptable et je vais vous
dire nous n'avons pas tous le même avis
ici dans cet hémicycle mais franchement
si ces jeunes cons rien si c'était des
banques six essais des entreprises
là on les aurait aidés là on les aurait
aidés là on aurait pu ses engagements là
on aurait elle a eu la promesse tenue
donc ne réfléchissez pas une mort à la
place de ces îles sont en survie et
notre société sa cohésion sociale est en
danger madame la ministre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]